[Music]
today we have sannyam bhutani
who runs the chai time data science
podcast and youtube channel
he started by talking about what it was
like to be a content creator
whenever a new people from any reputed
institute
or anywhere comes out we all get excited
about it but if you read the paper and
if you're an outsider you wouldn't be
able to make heads or tails out of it
we spent a bit of time talking about
kaggle samyam has had the ceo of kaggle
on his podcast and also abhishek thakur
who is a triple grandmaster at kaggle we
spoke in some detail about the utility
of kaggle
and how much these solutions to a kaggle
competition
generalized to real world instances of
the same problem
how much of their time is going into
something that is relevant
for let's say the company that's hosting
the competition
and how much of their time is going into
packs that are just for the competition
sanyom is currently working at h2o which
is a machine learning platform company
we spoke a little bit about his
experience working at h2o
how he landed himself a job there and
indeed their product
right now i work with the best team i
get to learn a lot from our grandmasters
we spoke about whether you need a formal
education
to learn machine learning is it possible
to just learn it online in the community
or does it really help you to go to
university self-taught i like to call
myself community taught because i've
learned through the forums
here at university i at least
see that we kind of haze the people
through a semester of do it now there's
an exam fill it out
probably cs231n as sayak said that was
that was probably the most instructive
course for me to
grok deep learning we also moved the
conversation a little bit beyond data
science
and spoke about cloud architecture and
software engineering
and machine learning engineering i think
with machine learning we are hyper
focused on a very small part of the life
cycle
and there are many broad themes in the
software engineering life cycle for
machine learning it's
data engineering it's data science and
software engineering and it's also
security and governance and that is
marshaling the cultural divide between
science and engineering finally in the
show today
we talk about patterns testing an
adversarial examples
i really hope you enjoy it remember to
like comment
and subscribe and we'll see you back
next week
mr culture hello alex is
this is this is one of the less silly
ones i had a great uh phone call with
the family
over the weekend and i found a but
before we get started i'll show you some
of the good ones that
came out of this there's this one
oh that's that's priceless
and uh another one that worked pretty
well
was this one here
i like that
and what was the other good one oh yeah
this one here this one it works pretty
well
[Laughter]
so good i might stick with this one for
the the podcast and see how we go
are you thinking i don't feel so good
about mine
i'll go back to i'll go back to my nice
green environment
welcome back to the machine learning
street talk youtube channel and podcast
with me tim scarf and my compadres today
so we have alex basie and stan lake
we've got sayak the neural network
pruner
and we've got yannick lightspeed culture
and today we have an incredibly special
guest
we have saiyan bhutani now uh siam is a
machine learning engineer and ai content
creator at h2o
i've been evaluating h2o work recently
it's got a really cool automl feature i
think it's the the best in the market
and it's really
good platform for citizen data
scientists so we can talk about that
uh cyan was very active on kaggle during
which his rank peaked at the top one
percent across all three tiers and
siam is clearly a huge fan of kaggle and
we'll discuss that in some detail today
um he's a huge content creator he runs
the chai time data science uh podcast
and youtube channel
which is quite literally our number one
competitor
we've invited our number one competitor
on the show that's how
pragmatic and and uh outward looking we
are here on street talk but
he's had some incredible guests
including thomas wolfe jeremy howard
abhishek takur who's a triple grand
master on kaggle
and also the man the legend connor
shorten
his podcast has been streamed a hundred
and twenty thousand times and four
hundred thousand hours
and he says he runs the podcast as a
service to the community
respectfully declining any sponsorship
money take the money bro
take the money um so he's currently most
active across
the h2o.ai the machine learning tokyo
and fast ai communities
he's a forum moderator and he hosts
about 10 to 12 hours of study groups
every week
so this is actually super interesting so
we're going to be talking about the
online learning community and just the
whole kind of data science vibe on
online these days
he decided not to pursue a masters in
data science and he decided instead to
hit the job market which is a fairly
scary prospect actually so we're going
to discuss
contracting and the job scene and what
it's like to work remotely as a data
scientist um today
so anyway that's the show this evening i
hope you enjoy it and
siam welcome it's an absolute honour to
have you on thanks so much tim uh it's
it's funny you'd call chai time your
competition i i was watching i i think i
was the first episode of yours where you
had the drone footage from a forest and
i was like
i better end this podcast now i i have
no chance left
i i i really love so it's it's i get to
talk to
a lot of my heroes today and i'm sitting
across the screen from all of my heroes
i really love all of your content each
and every one of your psych i love your
blog yannick i love your channel and of
course the podcast is amazing so thanks
for having me
it's an absolute pleasure so i don't
know where you would like to start
there are so many things that we can
touch on here so why don't you just give
us a bit of a brief intro into how you
got to where you are now
and clearly you you have many branches
into the community through
online learning and through your kaggle
activities and your job at h2o
absolutely and it'll sound a bit random
because it is
i wouldn't lie to you how it all got
started and if
anything that connects all of this is
that i
try to pursue what i'm interested in and
if i enjoy it i'll continue with it
otherwise i'll put a stop to it as early
as i can
back in university i was trying to find
something that i was interested in
uh trying all the student clubs trying
all projects
and then someone told me hey you should
check out deep learning i was like all
right what start
and i went to my uh mentors and they
told me you know
this is something that only masters or
psc students study you should stay away
from it's not good for you
i was like all right i'm gonna do this
now that's how i got started
gradient descended my way across many
different things tried a lot of online
courses we didn't have
courses in my university we did but
i looked at the syllabus and i saw what
was going on twitter i didn't see any
remote
connections i was like okay i'm not
gonna pursue these from college i'm
gonna go online and find
uh ways to fill those gaps that's how i
got started right now what i do is
it involves a lot of content creation i
run the podcast like you mentioned
and also try to be a little active in
the community
so it's an intersection of these things
a really big thing that's
linking all of this together at the
moment and that's the role of content
creation
like because you're self-taught and a
lot of us are self-taught in part or
fully so
tell me how you view content creation
in the modern ai ecosystem how does that
fit in
is it just a thing we do to learn or is
it like the heart and soul
it's like you said it's definitely the
heart and soul
and how i look at it is whenever a new
people from
any reputed institute or anywhere comes
out
we all get excited about it but if you
read the paper and if you're an outsider
you wouldn't be able to make heads or
tails out of it
whenever mr culture puts out a video the
complete
subreddit is extremely excited i am
extremely excited hey i want to watch
this now it'll all make sense
and as content creators we're filling
those gaps right i'm sure companies or
research institutes are spending a lot
of money but
they have their own little community how
do we make this more accessible because
i'm sure all of us would agree that all
of this tech
eventually as it becomes tools will be
more accessible and we're just
helping connect those dots as uh being
content creators although i'm not as
remotely any good as all of the other
people in this call but that's how i
look at it
way too humble way too humble we've got
this we've got this world where
um we're creating this content to share
knowledge and make it accessible
i i definitely know that there's quite a
few guys out there
they're really talented they're
basically self-trained themselves or
went on to become content creators i'm
thinking uh
i don't know if daniel burke he's a guy
i met in brisbane he's a really
fantastic data science content creator
guys like him have no formal education
all they have is curiosity so does this
mean that the traditional model of
education of training
is dead is there still a role for it
like
how does training evolve from here i
i was and this is not to offend anyone
if you've seen the recent meme floating
around netflix it's like ten dollars a
month on college education is like what
ten thousand dollars a month that's the
situation right now the only upside
so to speak if if we had to to cart to
compare
for many of the degrees it will be hey
you get a great community at college you
get to meet so many people we don't have
that right now so people who can learn
by themselves have
a bigger positive on their side i would
say i don't call myself self-taught i
like to call myself community taught
because i've learned through the forums
i've
learned through yannick's videos i've
learned through your podcast
that's how i look at it and i also
interviewed daniel burke and
he also embarked on this journey just
documenting what he was learning
and he basically pursued his passion i
asked him how did you come up with that
ai masters degree blog that he had put
out he said i just googled it
saw all of the courses put them into a
list that made sense and that was one of
his top blogs
that really speaks to how all of us are
excited to get started with learning and
it's this hesitancy hey do i need a
masters
studied computer science from a good
university in india
i'll be honest i'm not a good coder i
don't think it gives me any benefit
as a tech person any chip on my shoulder
compared to others
i have to learn as much probably a
little more because i
just i'm so slow to learn with different
things up i don't think
if you're at university or not if it
makes any difference i don't think
there's any difference now
there's something to be said about that
there are clearly people who can
you know sit down and their curiosity is
so strong
they'll just go about it they'll learn
it and so on
and that's fantastic and i think these
people will if you give them like two
sticks and a block of silicon
they'll make a computer and learn
machine learning but
for the majority of people that's not
the case so we can talk about whether
this is a good thing or not but
here at university i at least
see that we kind of haze the people
through a semester of do it now there's
an exam fill it out
and i think for what i'm seeing in the
online community
is a lot of great introductory material
of and this is the things you can make
flashy and so on but i think when it
comes to the
like the advanced stages there like the
people who remain are
very few and just exactly like these
the people who are self taught by most
degree
it's what do you of course the price tag
of a couple of thousand bucks
for someone telling you to do something
that you actually signed up to do
is heavy but there is there might be a
role
in this right so what's the key element
then
is it curiosity or is it the structure
and formalism that
allows you to go beyond the introductory
stuff the easy stuff that's the secret
to success
so i i'm not an expert i'll be honest
and i still dabble a lot i
get bored keep switching context a lot
so i am not the person who sits down and
stays arted for a long time
which is why i am pursuing the podcast
as a regular mission just to
train my tenacity one thing i read in
one of the blog posts that from one of
my mentors francisco ingram
he said and this is true i think to
anything in life in general
the only way to not make it is to stop
pursuing it if you stay at it you either
become a practitioner or you keep trying
eventually you will become one
and to be to to compare things it's true
to university as well we start with a
bachelor's degree
and i'm not saying anything against
university i'm just saying for the
people who believe that
i can't afford to go to a college right
now you can learn this online if you're
in college
great you already have that community
but if you're a bachelor student
you might not be tempted to go back into
that cycle of taking tests
submitting assignments doing that in the
middle of life
and pursue a masters and even lesser of
those people would go for a phd that's
that's true to
learning online as well just that you
have lesser people to keep you
accountable so what i did was
find ways of keeping myself accountable
i would just randomly tweet out my
annual goals and do annual reviews as if
it was a board meeting going on so every
year i do
okay uh goal review time i failed this i
did this
uh here's what happened next year i'll
do this it's of course true and and i
have to say i'm at a
i'm at a very special place where i
think we are
the one of the few top universities
that offers degrees for a semester here
for a master's student costs what 600
bucks
and actually a phd semester costs 72
72 swiss francs which is like 70 dollars
just and actually you're getting paid in
addition for the phd but the semester
i'm not in an authority to say i think
here it makes sense but it's a special
case
what i'm a bit worried about is the
intermediate
so i see a lot of these online
universities popping up
where they make you pay a lot
which is it gives the flair of a
university but then when you look at
their curricula and i've been asked to
per
to be a teacher for some of these when
you look
they're they're more serious ones let's
call them ambitious but then there are
no no coding required no requirements
zero zero requirements there is like one
semester or two semesters and at the end
you'll be a neural network expert and
you look at their curricula in
two weeks of neural networks and then
there's a week of
cnns and the week of lstms and that's it
and no coding required at the beginning
so week one is
python how to python so
i don't know what you you people think
about the but i see
these kind of degrees rising these
degrees where
it seems to be just about credentialing
it seems to be you want to lure and then
these people be like oh i have this
thing and they'll get to a company and
the company doesn't know
they'll hire so yeah i'm a bit worried
about that
yeah i think this is exactly where a bit
of formalism
and the kind of university like
structures come into play because as you
rightfully mentioned when it comes to
introductory level courses or
intermediate intermediary level courses
probably there are a lot of online
resources but when it comes to
really the advanced stuffs like advanced
nlp offered by
christopher manning and his students and
stuff you will hardly
find any resource to be matching that
quality right cs231n
or probably cs224n these are
the all of these are coming from
university students and university
professors so that is exactly where you
go get to know about those qualities the
current version of cs231a they teach you
about image transformers like
this is exactly where a bit of
university like structure and universe
is like formalism
can really help but i'm of course not
against
the great online resources that we have
of course have to appreciate
andrew young's courses on machine
learning the deep learning
specialization and
all of the stuff that deep learning ai
in particular is coming up with
come on lucas kaiser teaches you there
about nlp reformers and stuff like that
who does that
so again jeremy then there's jeremy
howard for example we get to learn about
cyclical learning rates
discriminative learning rates which
other course i do not know i do not know
about any other course that
teaches you research that really matters
into production and stuff like that
so i think when you have that holistic
and systematic approach toward
curiosity and really learning stuff and
chasing stuff and
pursuing your passion in a holistic way
without getting any kind of bias into
your way
like you are okay to pursue that one
stuff from
more formalized kind of manners from
more formalized kind of courses
i think as long as you are true to your
passion and you
have already developed an understanding
of how you would like to pursue things
you are in a good place that's what so
psych was just talking about jeremy
howard
and when jeremy howard came on the scene
i was really skeptical loads of people
at microsoft were saying oh you've got
to check out fast ai
and i looked at it and i just thought it
was full of hacks i thought it was all
of this
tricks to do different image sizes and
cyclical learning rates and warm
restarts and
with these learning rate hacks and i
just thought it was a load of nonsense
frankly and i was almost being quite
elitist saying this is not focused on
the actual underlying theory and there's
always a tug of war isn't there between
some folks in the community say you need
to know about linear algebra and you
need to have a very formal
kind of education around some of these
things and that lady from google cassie
she says we
we need chefs so we don't need people
that can build the ovens and
because you know learning about the
algorithms is actually like building
the microwave isn't it it's not cooking
the food so
so putting this to you because i know
you talk about kaggle as well a lot of
people say that kaggle is just
a bit of a bit of a hack fest and people
are just trying all of these different
things randomly together and not really
understanding how they work from a low
level so do you
and as an aside by the way i've learned
deep learning many years after i left
university i've learned it
in the last few years and probably
cs231n as sayak said that was
that was probably the most instructive
course for me to
grok deep learning so i certainly didn't
need to go to university to learn any of
it and actually i would say now that if
you wanted to learn this at an advanced
level
yannick culture's youtube channel was
the best place on the internet i think
yannick's the next andrew ng
where do you draw the line here i think
you can get started in any way how i did
was i dived
straight into deep learning which means
i missed a lot of stuff
right outside the frame of this webcam i
have the esl book
the intro to statistical learning books
all of them piled up in a nice
corner there eventually you have to
learn those that's how i look at it sure
the thing that surprises me is how
easily you can get started
so the barrier to entry is very low but
then
to be really good at it to someone like
mr culture you need to
go through a lot of learning you need to
apply a lot of these things
and uh just to add to sye's point i
think i i'm a fan of his work
and he's been learning after he came out
of university it's a continuous process
for
us i'm sorry i'm speaking on your behalf
but here's what i know
and you're contributing to tensorflow
you're writing these amazing blogs
that's a continuous learning effort and
you need to remain conscious hey what's
a good process what's
a good learning curve for myself okay
this is a tough problem
is it outside of my grasp or do i need
to
put enough put in some effort to be able
to grasp it that's how i look at it and
again
you have to do your due diligence about
what courses might work
for farcier personally i was very
intimidated about taking the course
because they mentioned hey you need one
year of python programming experience
i was in my sophomore year i was like
okay i know what
for loops and classes are but i don't
have industrial experience am i
qualified enough to take this course so
i was on the complete opposite side
in that phase and what do you think
because jeremy howard as well he
he courts controversy everywhere for
example jupiter notebooks
are antithetical to software engineering
and he's actually built this entire
platform called mbdev
proving that you can do unit testing and
code coverage and engineering
fundamentals in jupiter notebooks and
he just seems to go against the grain
everywhere but you can't help but like
the guy
he he talked about how he was i think he
invented
uln fit and he also solved many image
classification challenges using just one
gpu where the big players were using
many gpus so
he's one of these guys that goes against
the grain and just manages to
almost democratize or bring deep
learning to the masses so you can't
really
you can't say anything bad about that
right i'm not an expert what i've
learned through is whatever i've learned
through some word related to fast a but
how i look at it is
everyone uh teaches their own formats in
the deep learning dot ai courses
somewhat different i have it right now
on my right here on my table as little
funnily enough
with a nice bookmark in the middle but
everyone has their own teaching approach
and everyone has their own opinion some
people really like va's code
it's great for browsing libraries and i
i had never used it
the first time i downloaded i was
completely overwhelmed oh that's so easy
you can easily navigate code
basis so conveniently so again it's an
iterative process i feel like
what i did was i tried jupiter notebooks
for a bit uh yeah they work really well
for me
then someone mentioned hey you should
look at vim
and then after trying to figure out how
to equip the screen for two days
when i finally learned that i was like
okay maybe this isn't sticking really
well for me because i don't ssh into a
machine i sit at my desk at my computer
it works okay for me
so i'm sticking to jupiter notebooks
again i think it's in
a process of experimentation if you feel
you're learning through kaggle uh
and if it doesn't feel so hacky to you
if you feel like whatever you're
applying to competitions is actually
teaching you something
do it worked okay for me i learned a lot
if
there again there are two things if
learning is too hard you might give up
or if you are staying at it for a long
time and you're still not learning maybe
it's not the best thing so i think
it comes through experimentation but
again i'm not an expert in
any of these things on the subject of
kaggle like
obviously it's got value for practicing
with data sets etc
but what's the broader value of kaggle
because i know a lot of companies have
thought to themselves hey we'll have a
kaggle competition we'll run a quick
accelerated r d
program see what happens goes into
production the whole thing goes bang
because data sets move over time etc and
they've got a bit more of a handle on
like
data set drift in later competitions but
certainly around 2017
2018 there were all these i wouldn't
call them high profile disasters but
things that didn't work so well
because the competition format isn't
necessarily the ml engineering
con format how would you change kaggle
to make it so that there was less of a
jump
between competition ml and
say live ml in production or ml research
to take another approach that's a great
question
and a full disclosure i haven't put many
models into production i have put a few
through my freelance experience
but again i think it's a lot of value
add for the competition host because
again they get so much r d coming out of
the competition now they can look at
this stuff and evaluate for themselves
hey
okay you can cherry pick whatever you
think would work best
and use it for your own good i think
they they have been taking care of these
things by imposing some constraints so
now you have the kernels only
competition we have to do anything
everything inside of the kaggle
environment so you're constrained by
that and
those are good enough constraints those
aren't like still very liberal
or you have kernels only influence where
hey you can train something offline but
it needs to be able to
complete inference within a few
constraints which are still reasonable
so i think they're still still uh moving
in the right direction i don't think i
would uh suggest they need
anything differently to them could you
give us an example because
i've not done many competitions i did
the whale tail identification one and i
did the microsoft malware one and i
think i did the
quora question answer pairs one
which was looking at entailment between
pairs of texture and says
throw us an example sure so
there are two different categories
essentially the first one is train
and run inference on notebooks so now i
forget whatever
gpu they support and whatever cpu
constraints are there but essentially
you
get a certain number of reasonable odds
hours which is
if i remember correctly somewhere in
eight or ten hours so a model needs to
train in
that limit and you need to be able to
complete the inference within
an hour or two and i don't remember if
the cpu and gpu are enabled or not
to me that seems reasonable right and
for the inference only competition
you're allowed to train offline
but when you're running inference when
you're trying to predict using kaggle
kernels
which would have lower hardware if
you're training online
offline they would have lower hardware
than your machines
you need to make sure that your model
can produce the predictions
in a certain number of hours so that you
can't do those crazy
100 level ensembles you're somewhat
constrained there it's
somewhat of a better output for putting
into production
so from experience do you
have an estimate of how much of
kaggle of caglers let's
you know look at the typical cagler that
do it does it really to win
how much of their time is going into
something that is relevant
for let's say the company that's hosting
the competition
and how much of their time is going into
hacks that are just for the competition
is it like
oh there's five percent at the end where
we do this for kaggle or
is it actually ninety percent is going
to get that
final one percent
i would argue that it's also on the
competition host to make
the format it's not it's the competition
that's being hosted by them so it's not
disjoint now they need to make sure that
the competition goals align with their
goals
there is some extra effort if you look
at the top positions for some
competitions
uh it's just the last digit that makes a
difference
but for some competitions there's this
huge jump where the first
three teams found something that no one
else could in those three months of no
sleeps
find so again it's a mix of things for
different competitions but i'd say
the hosts are still getting a lot of
value which is why we get to see so many
competitions happening still
do you think any of the practices in
kaggle are almost antithetical
to what you would need in production in
a real company
i'll give an example so if you set up an
ml engineering pipeline now
you have a weird interaction between
science and engineering
so the data scientists will build their
model probably interactively
using something like a tutor notebook
and then they might create a validation
notebook and they'll create a whole
bunch of
business key performance indicators and
validation metrics and they might even
use some interpretability methods and so
on and then
at some point they'll hand over to an ml
engineer and the ml engineer will do
linting and unit testing and
possibly counterfactual examples and
data grouping and fairness and so on and
they'll work together cyclically and
they'll use pull requests and they'll
converge on a solution which has more
engineering rigor
so it can run as part of a pipeline and
on these kaggle competitions you tend to
see
the people using all of these methods
glued together on ensembles and this
thing glued to that thing and this weird
pre-processing
and it's quite difficult to validate
that and it's quite difficult to test it
so do you think that's something that or
maybe you could just do it once but you
couldn't iterate
on it or if you did iterate on it it
would behave strangely do you think
that's not really useful for the
business world is it just a kaggle thing
yes to some extent i agree and i had
interviewed anthony goldblum as well the
ceo of kaggle
we agreed on one point that kaggle is
missing on
stuff that relates to putting things
into production and things in the side
of
the world of de-biasing models and
making them interpretable
and also you're missing out on the
engineering part how did you get the
data there
how did they convert it into a business
problem whatever competition you're
looking at
someone went through the process of
figuring out okay we have these 100 gb
of excel sheets
how do we change these columns into a
format where we can put it into a ppt
that makes sense to people that
are the actual stakeholders and then
provide it to us we're missing all of
those details
but again the value that you get out of
kaggle
or that i have gotten is a lot which is
why i i remain to be a big fan
of the platform it's not like kaggle has
to solve every problem
it's oh there's this stuff missing but
i'm i'm just thinking of like
research right here and the code we
write is
if it i write horrendous and then there
is like a two-week sprint to the
deadline and
at the end if it still runs and i have
try
i'll try catch pass
this is my construction whenever it
fails i just don't care as long as
something runs
at the end it's good so it's not
that we everything has to solve every
problem
i think honestly kaggle is is quite
awesome at what it's doing and
continuously
improving i was just trying to add
on top of what janik just mentioned
regarding research i think
many of the kaggle competition winners
do put up papers on archive and
also they present about their work at
popular conferences which
which technique is it was there that
they eventually ended up with
in order to win a competition and they
also try to you know justify
their methods to some extent and one
immediate one that i can
think right off the top of my hand is
ndd embeddings if
that is especially useful for
using neural networks for tabular
datasets again it's something that i
learned from jeremy howard
but ngdm buildings are really useful not
only
just for using tabular datasets with
neural networks but they are useful in
general
extracting useful and meaningful
representations from far
from tabular datasets probably was
trivial before
ntdm buildings came into the picture and
again we have a very well written paper
on that particular subject so i think
things are heading to a direction where
we can actually expect
justified work from the competition
winners
and we do have evidences about that
has anyone ever done like a a
cross-sectional study of the feature
engineering methods used in kaggle
because there's this what would you call
it an essay
called the the bitter truth out on the
internet at the moment basically
positing that
sutton there you go i'm bad with author
names the
general idea is over time the models
that have best been able to exploit
computational power have progressed
forward now if you read research papers
there are a lot of papers that say hey
this method is what gets us our 0.01
additional improvement therefore it is
the new state of the art
so much of this stuff comes out at the
same time you compare this to say like
kaggle where they really just go let's
try
everything random and then just do a
great big grid search
and call it a day do does anyone know if
anyone's
actually looked into these different
strategies to see which
works better overall and to counter your
point
some people do run random grid searches
the people that can't
but many of the experienced cargo
especially the names that you always see
on the top of the leaderboards every now
and then they
know at least much more than what i'm
doing out there
and they know where to start and i think
that again comes through this experience
of
running so many experience i read in an
article like steve jobs had this cut
intuition for great products good data
scientists no way to
start an experiment or from where to
start those things
so i think it really hones your skill of
testing those things out because it's
it's such a real world experience right
you're competing against
so many real people there's a live
leaderboard it's a slap in your face
straight up front if you're not good
you're going to fall down the
leaderboard the leaderboard doesn't lie
so that's how i look at it
yeah that was a really interesting point
though from alex that there's this
cultural divide in machine learning at
the moment
and on one side of the divide you have
the max wellings
and they think that we need to have
better models and we need to have better
inductive priors and our models and of
course there are different ways of doing
that
but then there's this rich sutton guy in
his bitter lesson he says that we need
massive amounts of compute and data
and he says we should stop trying to
build overly simplistic models and
instead rely on on massive amounts of
compute
and he cites deep blue and and also
alphago
as being examples of where it was huge
amounts of searching or learning that
actually gave
us some progress it wasn't really it
wasn't human-crafted rules anymore
and i genuinely don't know the answer to
this because on kaggle as well
even the h2o product you work at h2o
they have this wonderful genetic
algorithm which searches across all of
these different featurizations of
of input data and then you try a bunch
of classical machine learning models on
the end of it and quite often that
outperforms
what human data scientists can come up
with and so you can make the argument
that this is just a kind of
this is just a brute force compute
problem or do you think we should be
smarter
to add more to what we do in our
products and i i think this is a
recurring theme to cargill as well many
people go along the route of excessive
compute and coming up with
this somewhat interesting stuff through
that hood but again it's a democratic
community whenever someone comes up with
that neat trick
they get a lot of up quotes whenever
they share it so uh we love that
and what we do is a smarter
grid search so it's not a great search
but essentially we call it a grand
master in a box
and it's better feature engineering or a
better grid search in the way that this
there's some smartness applied to what
areas would you like to look into and
not just do blind search across
everything and
anything possible that's an interesting
line of work to find yourself in and a
lot of people
find themselves in this place in various
ways how did you personally
find your way in right now i work
with the best team i get to learn a lot
from our grandmasters
how did i get started in freelance i
wanted to do projects
outside of the boring introductory ones
that janik had mentioned
i was frustrated of looking at that
same three neural network image that
would come at the end of every single
course every time whatever framework
they would teach it would always be the
same picture and i was frustrated off
looking at it
so i started going to communities
different slack groups and i just
started talking to people
what are you working on is what i'm
interested in
and i'd start looking up what they're
working on started playing around with
different things
then at some point in time someone was
asking some questions and i started
answering them
we had a conversation and then they
offered me to help
them i was like sure of course i am free
i don't care about my college
assignments i'll do it and after that
they asked me how much are you gonna
charge me i was like wait what
you're gonna pay me for doing this
you're gonna pay me for
working on a project that i really want
to work on
that was my first project and that again
snowballed into
me connecting with different people
through that same person they introduced
me to more people
again it was driven through my own
curiosity i was just trying to find
projects that
i would like to explore and getting paid
for them
and this happened because i wasn't
allowed to have a job in my college i
was
in my sophomore year still trying to
find something that was of interest to
me that's how it got started again very
random it sounds much nicer now
that i put it in this way but it was
very random
so again it was a lot of learning i'm
still learning like i said
but when someone's paying you and you
sign that contract which mentions that
you might go to prison if you don't make
the deadline
things get real that's that was the
deadline maker for me i was in college i
didn't care about deadlines deadlines
don't mean anything in college he was
you submit assignments a week late
you're fine you just apologize to
professor you're good
but when you sign that document which
states that
in the con in the state of california
they can drag you there and do stuff to
you
put you into prison i'm just making it
too dramatic but that made things real
for me and then you start paying more
attention to things
i was in university i wasn't as serious
which is why i'm making more dramatic
but
that's how i became more accountable
deadlines make a wishing noise when they
fly past
douglas adams who said that i can't
remember but you're now working at h2o
and i'm quite intrigued by h2o they've
got an interesting platform for machine
learning they call it platform studio
they've got
queue which is a kind of i suppose a
business intelligence and
and querying and you know analytics
platform they've got driverless ai which
i think is the coolest thing that you've
got so that's this wonderful
web application you log into it you can
ingest your data and it will essentially
run this genetic algorithm and it will
do
all kinds of featurizations and
recombinations similar to deep learning
the way it works actually
and you might think this is horrible
because how do i do interpretability how
do i understand how it works that's all
built in as well there's even a slide
bar where you can say
i want to have this amount of
interpretability so it will it won't do
certain transformations and that will
inform
the type of algorithms that are
suggested and the type of approach you
can take
and then it even has all of these
different interpretability
visualizations so it's got k
lime in there and it's got um all sorts
of methods in there for assessing
fairness and so on so that's cool you've
got a spark based version called
sparkling water and you've also got a
model
manager for doing ml devops yeah it's
essentially all of
these are different flavors of auto ml
automated machine learning many people
confuse that with self-driving cars
that's not the case this is for
automating the machine learning process
but if i were to talk about tribal sci
it's more about how
does a data scientist use this tool so
it's not it can do an end-to-end project
i like to call it the ironman dashboard
just because it looks so cool the first
time i tried it
you can do the essentially the
end-to-end pipeline of what would
involve in a
data science role along with the tool so
you can also just leave it on
auto everything mode but you can then
also go into
the tool fiddle around with the settings
bring your own code we call it bring
your own recipe
essentially it's again a data scientist
in a box
has anyone ever tried maybe not of you
but does anyone know if
anyone has tried negative
interpretability can you put the slider
to negative one
and that would make the model be like
you want to interpret this
screw you i'm gonna make it as hard as
possible like
my features are like oh two of this and
five thousand of this
and you'll have no clue it'd be funny i
don't know if there's an
application but is this a thing
negative interpretability like
obfuscation for code
yeah it's called deep learning
in our product again it's different
scales so essentially you get these
three knobs as if you like
i like to call it as if you like the
iron man sitting across the jarvis
dashboard and you can tune which setting
do you want more do you have time
tune up the time setting do you want it
to be more performant do you know the
performance
now of course you're losing on
interpretability again it's three skills
that essentially allow you to choose
broadly that's the summer intern mode
you can hit launch it'll do everything
for you
but again if you're an expert you can go
into the settings and configure them
it's a grand master team it's a grand
master team i think we have about 18 of
the world's kangaroo grandmasters
working at hsu.a and it's all of their
rich experience through all of these
competitions that we were talking about
put
into a project which is why we also call
it a grand master in a box
well i've literally had a model learn to
give itself nands so that it gets a low
score
which is something that i'd never
honestly expected to see that's a new
state of the art
yeah you should be surprised you should
publish that
but in a sense this is a good thing
though because i think all of the
vendors are they're other vendors in the
space as well like data iq they're all
building
interpretability methods in into their
systems because we're in a post-accuracy
world now
where we recognize that models need to
behave in a way which we understand and
intend and
there are certain there are certain
things that we don't want to
discriminate on and we want to
stratify over certain features or
dimensions and and we want to be
learning on others
essentially you trained a model now what
it's a question for both
people who are putting things into
production and also people who are
learning you trained a model now what do
you do with it
that's right but even in h2o you can
have interpretability as one of your
target metrics
or fairness as one of your target
metrics so it's a and potentially a new
way of
training a model as well as
introspecting after you've trained
absolutely and we've seen cases where we
had issues with
credit lending across industries not at
h2o but across different industries
where
due to some biases and models we had
issues of issuing credit cards
and you wouldn't want these to happen at
a scale where wired is writing an
article about it
so you need to make sure that you do
checks before things happen
when they're put out into the real world
so it's definitely an important topic
and we play much very close attention to
it i know we've put out a book
on this as i can send over the link
afterwards but where we teach this
to people who aren't just using our
product but want to know about it they
can also grab that book
and i think it's for free fantastic
with you know these products these
automl products coming out across the
market
what role is there for people learning
ml now obviously there's going to be
some space around the edges for these
kind of boutique models for very unique
or unusual problems but
if 90 of it can be automated what
happens to everyone
on courses at the moment learning to do
this sort of stuff
you level up right that's how i look at
it if it's becoming automated you have
to level up
of course the tech catches up with our
interests
so it's just a tool in your toolbox
it'll remain to be a tool automl will
always be a tool in your toolbox it's
not an ai that is taking over data
scientists job
now that you have that part automated
can you do more interesting stuff and
can you bring the tool in
so that your job remains creative and
you don't have to worry about
the somewhat boring side of things is
how i i look at it
i had a question before maybe it's a bit
out of context now but
to the whole freelancing and so on and i
i was very interested and you said okay
i had this first project and that
snowballed into sort of more things
i a lot of people i think they are
wondering
what it takes to get that first job and
you were saying you were talking to
people on on slack and so on but
there is a if some random person like
talks to you in a slack group
like the chances you're going to hire
them is are pretty slim
what do you do you have any advice maybe
you've been through the process do you
have any advice
what would you recommend as like
the highest probable way to get that
first few
jobs to get that first few freelancing
things if you don't have the credentials
like it's super easy for someone who was
at
university like here i have a masters
and whatnot
but if you're self-taught how do you
enter
that's a great question and i i think it
doesn't have to be transactional
whenever you're first approaching
someone that's that
what really spooks someone off hey i
love your profile what you're doing uh
i'm interested in doing a job can you
help me you may not get a reply to that
because we
we as humans love making friends right
we love talking to each other but
we aren't always working don't always be
so transactional when you're reaching
out to someone that's one thing i see
some people make which makes sense if
you need a job you need a job
what i was doing was just chatting with
people about things i enjoyed
and just because i i think all of us
enjoy that dopamine rush right when we
watch your videos yeah nick i get that
dopamine rashf
oh i i learned about this amazing paper
today through your video
so that's what i was doing on the
community is just trying to learn
through
those discussions or just having a
interesting discussion
beyond that how i would approach people
when i knew they had a job posting or a
project posting would be
i need to sell myself that hey i can
actually build this
and it's funny in hindsight i it was
never a discussion of
how old i was or if i was doing my
bachelor's so they never asked me hey
where's your degree how much did you
score there
which is important in indian context
people care a lot about that
so what i would do is i would see what
project they are building
i would try to build whatever i could
along those lines in one or two days and
tell them hey i saw this
project of yours here's what i was able
to put together in two days
if you like i'd love to work on work
with you on this
i could build this in xyz days and i was
able to do this in two days if you give
me x days i could do something better
and i guess that was a great selling
point to many people
that is a there's an awesome
recommendation yeah
definitely and if not write a blog post
on it
make it more polish you will have to do
some code refining of course it'll be
very clunky
put a blog post on it make a video on it
it's already there right
it doesn't go state and if someone's put
a project on it
other people will eventually so it
doesn't go out of
context awesome i want to share
something
this is a potential architecture on aws
for doing
the life cycle of data science and
machine learning into production
but i think with machine learning we are
hyper focused on a very small part of
the life cycle
and there are many broad themes in the
software engineering life cycle for
machine learning it's
data engineering it's data science and
machine learning it's software
engineering and it's also security and
governance
and personally i think that the real
skills for you to be
picking up as a data scientist now are
mlops or data engineering
at scale or learning about security
methodologies
and learning about automated testing and
so on and if you wanted to templatize
this
you would need infrastructure as code
skills you would need to have
cloud architecture skills you would need
to know about how to transform
everything you've done interactively in
a jupyter notebook into a step function
you would need to know about container
services you would need to know about
sagemaker you would need to know about
data engineering using glue you'd need
to know about ingesting your data you'd
need to know about
ml devops you'd need to know about repos
template repos how repost could be
productionized
you'd need to know about how to build a
model registry how to do governance how
to do lineage how to do the security on
the data how to do high velocity scoring
api gateways you need to know about
monitoring you need to know about cloud
map and cloud watch
you see what i'm saying here that the
data scientists will be working in a
notebook here but
the key thing here is this
multi-disciplinary path to production
which involves many different skills
many different cloud technologies so
actually there's a lot of things to be
learned absolutely
yeah it's a big world so plenty of
opportunity
yeah probably cute let curiosity guide
your way and
find the stuff that you would like to
prioritize that you already do not know
and yeah let your let your keep keep
curiosity drive the way so yeah
do you think there are there are because
we're now saying oh the data scientists
working this notebook and so on but
right now our machine learning
is big our sagemaker models into
production
is not very big our repos
to a testable pipeline is also not very
big
like it's are too many people focused
on that wow let's build a model that's
super cool with this architecture and so
on and
do we have enough people that take care
of all the other steps is or is there
like a disparity
where eventually a lot of people will
have to switch over from being
the model builders to being the model
pipeliners well one of the fun things
about doing cloud stuff
is cloud stuff very broadly is that
there are
pretty awesome tools to get you there
where you just write
code and it builds your clouds your
cloud your cloud stack for
like with a single line of code you
suddenly have a complete deployment
pipeline with all your security set up
and you're hooked up to thousands of
users
user accounts it looks very scary when
it's all put
on the board like that but most of it's
really just the hardest part is
remembering
to assign the correct permissions for
the various groups
and then reading through like terraforms
documents because
terraform's a godsend but at times it's
poorly documented and you're
you're left trying to figure out the
gaps i'm not 100 sure about that
i think the to yannick's point there's a
huge issue at the moment with data
science myopia
oh yeah i think that we're obsessed with
data science and machine learning and
most models never go anywhere
they don't go into production that's why
even these democratized tools like
h2o they are trying to to build a path
to production
data iq is similar but the problem is
there's always an engineering deficit
there's always a deficit of engineering
skills
because engineering is all about process
it's all about taking what you've done
interactively as a data scientist and
making it run non-interactively
doing automated tests doing a
productionisation doing
zero downtime deployments doing a b
testing doing blue green deployments and
so on
all of this is a level of engineering
rigor that data scientists don't have
yeah basically never let your data
scientists design your cloud stack for
this exact reason
i know and we need to do this at the
meta level as well we need to do
infrastructure as code to create all of
these environments create all of this
infrastructure it needs to be ephemeral
which means we spin it up and then we
can tear it down afterwards we don't
have any shared environments
and it's actually really difficult to do
this and we want to have reusable assets
that people can build in an organization
we don't want people to reinvent the
wheel every time
we want to have a standard template for
this is how you do data engineering this
is how you do
a vision model this is how you put it
into production and all of this is about
standardization and getting people to
have common ways of working and in my
opinion that's the biggest challenge
that we have right now
to add to alex's point it's important to
know the difference between ch mod 400
777 that's one thing i would always mess
up yeah so
to tim last point so
as an wise man named joel groos once
suggested
you should incorporate some sort of
science and reproducibility into
engineering when you incorporate
digestified science in your engineering
pipelines you get to do
the engineering in a lot better way so
eventually he and and two folks at allen
nlp
uh came up with this hugely popular
presentation date called
writing code for nlp research so it was
one of the probably most viewed
tutorials of em nlp 2019 if i'm not
wrong
so i definitely encourage our viewers to
check that one out
because it really walks you through the
process of incorporating really well
defined science
into large scale production systems yeah
so
this is the broadway comparison between
programming
in small and programming in the large
and now the folks at tensorflow had
compared this to writing code for
machine learning
for small projects compared to writing
code for machine learning projects at
scale
so as you can see so this is
i like this comparison uh a lot because
it gives you the sort of very
brief overview as to things that that we
are probably very accustomed to
and to the things that we probably are
not that accustomed to so
yeah just a little bit yeah i completely
agree with all of that and a lot of it
is about scale
it's about getting large teams to work
together it's about
because these are multi-disciplinary
teams as well a lot of it is about yeah
standardizing ways of working it's about
infrastructure provisioning
templatization of projects software
engineering fundamentals security
and you said something else interesting
before which is the word reproducibility
and immutability and isolation this is a
core tenant in
ml architecture because we don't want
people using shared environments we want
to have predictable runtime
characteristics we want to know for sure
that this thing is going to work in
production and we do that with all of
these
methodologies we change one thing at a
time we test everything
we have immutable assets we know how
this model was created if it makes a
decision that we don't agree with we can
trace back
all the decisions or the hyper
parameters we know the data it was
trained on
and all of this is about standardization
and automation
and this is what you need because in a
highly regulated environment you need to
understand
what is in production and who tested it
and who signed it off
you need to build a whole system around
that i don't think these
principles are just at scale though i
think these are things that people in
general should work towards
as like just good common practice like i
know
yannick will say yeah but i was busy
writing the paper and
you know the code run without crashing
we're all good
but i'd argue that's if you do it right
from the beginning you don't have that
problem at the end
and a lot of people oh a lot of
researchers i speak to
code's kind of an afterthought but
really in in a day
where re reproducibility crises in
multiple fields
the best thing we can be doing is
transparency and part of that is good
clean readable code
so anyone can go in and know exactly
what's going on or try it in other
settings
testable code this test i would argue a
little bit against this because
the reproducibility crisis in
let's say in machine learning has little
to do with how
well the code is structured or how
readable it is because most people
when they if they publish their code
will run and the number that they say
comes out will come out it's just the
fact that if you change that
seed equals thing then by one
it drops by five percent so it's not the
code can be
can be very pretty and in addition to
that i've also been in situations
where i where it was clearly counter so
you can do this too much you can do this
too much this
oh let's do it right from the beginning
let's unit test everything so
let's say you unit test you unit test
your intermediate step
in your ml pipeline and you say okay
this is the exact structure
i want to come out of this and then you
input this and
in your unit test it says something like
oh if i input this example data point
then this
thing would come out now if i want to go
and experiment a bunch
and do my stuff then all these tests are
going to fail
and all these type definitions are going
to fail so i now need to go through five
levels of abstraction
50 unit tests and whatnot and change
that one parameter
every single time where i want to change
something so there is
i'm much more sympathetic to the unit
testing argument than clean code
the having to read someone's garbage
code to figure out
what they've done is nightmare fuel but
the testing
yeah i could agree with you on that
sorry just quickly you are touching on
the biggest challenge that we have in
this space and that is
marshalling the cultural divide between
science and engineering so science
people
explore engineers exploit that's the
basic difference
and we want to have scientists that can
use jupiter notebooks and have
freedom to experiment with models and
interactively chip away at parameters
and so on
but then it has to become something
which can run non-interactively with
certain guarantees and tests
the scientists and the engineers have to
converge on a common understanding and
they have to increase the rigor because
when scientists write the code they
don't even use functions they just use
cells in a jupyter notebook
you have to um have a standard contract
of how this gets promoted you need to
have a pre-processing
pre-processing python file a training
python file an inferencing python file
you need to have dependency management
you need to have testing
and just to yannick's point this is
something which converges slowly and
when it's converged the data scientist
is still a first-class citizen in the
productionization process but they can
only change very small things
if the data scientist wants to go back
into experimentation mode they need to
start again basically
so i i had interviewed the author of
this book as well which i have
conveniently on my table
ian oswald and we talked about unit
testing there as well so the first
project that i did i was in my sophomore
year and that's me being lucky that's
not
to mention that hey i did a project so i
didn't know about unit test
and very fortunately the person for whom
i did the project
was a product manager who came from an
engineering background
and they asked me for a zoom call after
making the payment i was like sure uh
maybe
they just want to discuss something and
that guy scolded the hell out of me is
this how you write
code where are the tests i'm like what
test it works dude like
you paid me what more do you want now
and at that day i realized okay so
there's something known as
test which i had very conveniently
skipped in my assignment
because i didn't care now i went on the
complete
opposite side which was now i'm gonna
test and put that percentage time it
across every single module in my code
and keep figuring it out
that's again an extreme and what i have
learned works well is
make sure the libraries are in the right
uh version make sure you've loaded the
tensors in the right shape so that you
don't get the mismatch error
the again you need you need to find it
the right balance and it's it's there
for
for auto ml how we handle it in our
products in a
driverless year you have a single click
download button which downloads a jar
file we call it mojo
and it doesn't have any python
dependencies you can download just a
java file
put it into production it's highly
scalable and you also have autodog
because we were talking about regulated
industries we have
customers in highly regulated industries
in finance
so what auto doc does is it shows you a
proper documented format
of how these industries would want your
experiment to be
which i can promise almost no data
scientists would like to
document everything in that format and
you can just submit that document to
them so now you have the complete
process that happened behind the scenes
it tells the document tells you how the
feature engineering was done what models
were built
how was the future importance picked and
what made it to the final pipeline
yeah again you could use a tool for it
or you could uh automate that part
that's the kind of thing that in the
enterprise i like to use templatization
around
particular particular predictive
architectures and generally speaking
data scientists should have a large
notebook which does all of their
validation
and they'll be some of the metrics they
record will just be numbers
and they need to be logged somewhere
into aws cloudwatch or into app insights
if you're using azure
and they need to there needs to be some
kind of a dashboard
which allows the product owners and the
business to sign off and to promote
certain models into production
but there also needs to be an ai
dashboard at the company level so that
people can see
how much money am i spending on ai
projects at the moment and where are my
metrics at
and don't get me wrong we've spoken
about metrics to great length
metrics can be incredibly dangerous and
if you optimize on metrics you can
create all sorts of weird perverse uh
incentives and shortcuts but
frankly we we need to have metrics at
some point because otherwise what have
we got to go on
one of the metrics we use for example is
you've got to have 95
code coverage in all of your tests and
like you can think about that and say is
that actually a smart thing i guess so
that just means that stuff's been tested
but it doesn't really tell you anything
about how good the test is but
but you need to have some kind of
metrics because otherwise these are
complex multi-disciplinary teams
and you need to have some way of getting
these folks to work together
even with the time frame that you have
and again everything in the industry is
put under constraints right so you have
a deadline
for things to hit production now you
could optimize stuff in within that
deadline
but again in your code when you're
thinking through that what you want to
optimize the ram usage for a pipeline
or the cpu usage up there are sometimes
trade-offs
ram is cheaper when you're putting
things into production sometimes you can
make that trade-off again
it's an open discussion for everything
yeah and even that's interesting by the
way is when you design these pipelines
quite often
you might need to use heterogeneous
computes and on aws you have
step functions for doing workflow
management or people might use kubeflow
and then you might have
some gpu hardware here and some cpu
hardware there and
if you're doing large scale
featurization of vision models you might
there's a compute versus storage
trade-off so you might say okay i'm just
going to featurize it
as part of my pipeline or i'm going to
pre-featurize it and store it in my data
it's yeah it's it's really it's
difficult anyway by the way you can
probably tell i've been thinking a lot
about this recently we've got a team
from aws
coming on the show in a few weeks time
talking all about ml engineering so come
back and listen to that it'll be a great
conversation
looking forward to hearing that one i've
listened to all of the episodes please
put out more of them uh
but put out two weeks put out three each
week i'll listen to every one of them
so with respect to garbage code and
readability alex we we haven't i argue
we haven't even scratched the surface
you can use like emojis in source code
and stuff like that how how else are
they meant to know that i'm having a
good day if i don't leave an emoji there
this is going to be like my next
variables are going to be for
smiley face in frowning days oh the
batman
symbol means that this pass didn't work
too well so we'll have to start the code
again
i i draw the line at copy pasting that's
where i i
go to people i say no rewrite the code
because copy pasting
40 you know every layer in a resnet is
just like
where did you learn to code what are you
doing have you not heard of functions
but to add to that point again it's an
iterative process like when i started
out i would
even when working on projects now that
i'm out of those contracts i can say
that
i would just look up code that i could
copy because i came from that hacker
mindset right i'm a computer science
student i can do this as long as i know
what it's doing
now i know the importance of hey it's
not just meant to work you need to make
sure it's readable by other people as
well code is read more than it's written
so once you hit that marker or when
someone scores you on a zoom call
then you improve upon it
here's an open question for every one of
you alex mentioned that
your code should be readable from the
very beginning you should try to
attend to the readability and
testability part of your code and
he was also sympathetic to the
testability side
so here's what i'm gonna assert here so
when you try to achieve a lot of things
from the very beginning to some extent
it hurts your productivity a bit
a lot yeah it agreed but
i'd say there's still a baseline you can
do like you don't just
you don't just trash your entire kitchen
as you're making a meal you clean up a
little bit
as you go and that that's all it takes
if you maintain it in a
maybe not a production ready state
something that with 10 15 minutes you
can tidy everything up and have
someone else look hand it over to
someone very quickly
then it doesn't it it's not a big effort
at the end to refactor everything and
introduce new bugs as you go
because you've just you've kept it good
from the beginning
but what you're talking because i think
your question was when you introduce
engineering rigor does it slow things
down the answer is
yes 100 it slows it down massively of
course it does but
the whole reason we do this is is we
need to have standardization and we need
to have certain things that we manage
even on data engineering pipelines for
example so you might have a company data
lake
and the data lake is basically a file
system in the cloud
what could possibly go wrong now imagine
if you let all of your data engineers
just interactively have access to the
data lake
it's going to be a swamp within days
they're just going to start copying
things all over the place
so you need to it's not just technology
it's process and people you need to
educate people you need to have
standardized ways of how you do
role-based access control how people get
access to the data you need to have
standard templates for doing data
engineering
that will publish metadata into a global
catalog so it's discoverable by other
people so you can do data lineage
all of this stuff is a pattern it's a
way of working and if you want to make
it clear that i feel
personally attacked right now by these
statements i'm feeling
personally attacked but this is why
because if the thing is
the the biggest thing in the enterprise
is basically protecting people from
themselves
so you never let data scientists or data
engineers have direct access to the data
like they have to follow a process
they'll fill out some form they'll get
some sysop accounts generated they'll
will create a virtual environment for
them and we'll scaffold everything for
them and what we're doing is we're
protecting them from messing everything
up
and it's the same thing with software
engineering rigor as well the first
thing you do is you add pull requests
and then you do automated builds and
then you do automated tests
and what you're doing here and metrics
and and approval gates and different
environments and a b
testing and so on and what you're doing
here is you're putting all of these
blockers in the way
because you're convinced that they're
going to ruin it if you don't check it
for them i will be the leader of the
revolution of the data scientists
you you will take our commit access but
you will never take
our freedom
what's the principle behind this maximum
access that's the best practice right
of course look in in an ideal world you
would have one
super data scientist who is
multi-disciplinary a full stack that
that you probably heard this term full
stack data scientist i'm a bit skeptical
about that term
if you had this very small company where
one person was doing everything then
perhaps you wouldn't need to have all of
this process
but yeah yeah i was trying to think it
through from a researcher's mindset
probably
they have something to quickly try upon
probably they have some idea has struck
their mind and
they just want to spin up a collab
notebook and just just
they want to try that idea out so in
that point of view
what would you suggest regarding
regarding engineering good
to janik's original point and just to
mention i understood a few of the terms
that tim was throwing out there not all
of them i i was able to make sense of a
few words he was mentioning just a few
minutes ago
it's not incentivized right now in the
proper format janik's writing a paper he
meets the deadline it's all good now he
doesn't need to refactor the code
if they had incentives in place to make
sure that
they don't have to go through the mess
of the kitchen and they want a nicely
presented dish
of course he would do that but we now he
has another deadline that's coming up
i'm just speaking on your behalf
pardon me but we need incentives in
place i think for research and
again it's an open question even for
data science right we need to figure out
how to put things into place
some people agree that you should use
jupiter notebooks just because of the
experimentability
some people disagree the truth i think
is somewhere in between some people
really love working in notebooks
if that doesn't work for production
which sometimes it does not
now you need to figure out a pipeline of
how do you put that into proper scripts
in a format that it's not just a copy
paste of the complete notebook so that
you get those errors of
the cells that would otherwise be
dumping stuff and that doesn't work in
scripts unfortunately
i think this this comes back to
exploration versus exploitation
i spoke to gartner about this and they
were very clear they said treat your
data scientists like a dirty puddle
let them do what they want but control
it greatly and because i'm a big
believer the data scientists should be
first-class citizens in the process but
actually that's rubbish because there
needs to be
lots of stage gates there needs to be
humans in the loop so it's a bit of a
pipe dream anyway
but i'm a strong believer that we need
to have freedom for
exploration and even in the world of
science we don't have that we've been
talking about broader impact statements
lately
and they are just a way of formalizing
conformalizing thought even in science
if you've got the wrong opinion then
you're not allowed to publish your work
and even the way the peer review system
works is it's a consensus mechanism
that people have to agree that your id
is good and all that's going to do is
reinforce the status quo
genuinely to be innovative we have to be
explorers
we have to try new things unconstrained
so i agree i think data scientists
should be able to do whatever the hell
they want
the challenge is when you move into that
exploitation phase
and to what extent can the data
scientists still be first-class citizens
in that exploitation phase afterwards
don't give them root access to aws
you'll get you're gonna get a good deal
after that
to your point sonya it's you're
absolutely correct and it's even worse i
am
i am massively counter-incentivized from
releasing
good readable code because like the
worst thing that can happen is someone
discovers a bug in my code
because then my whole project is in
jeopardy
so i am i'm massively incentivized to
release
the crappiest code where my doc says
just
oh just uncomment lines five to ten if
you want to do this other thing
really this this is i have zero
incentive to do anything else i
absolutely agree with you that we need
to change this and maybe incentivize
if we want better code out of her
scientist and i also agree with
with tim i think the most frustrating
thing
i don't know because i am not a data
scientist in a big organization
but a frustrating thing i can imagine is
you have a good idea
and you just want to try it out and then
there are all these hurdles
right so it's i want to quickly try this
feature but then it's i don't have
access to this and i don't have access
to that and i can't run this without
this other person's approval and this
test is failing
so yeah tim what's the you're saying
data scientists should be first-class
citizens
what's the kind of best
single thing one can do to make this
happen in a pipeline in a company
so when i said first-class citizens i
mean in the ongoing productionization of
assets
and first of all machine learning can be
productionized in many ways it might be
part of software it might
because machine learning has one foot in
the analytical world and one foot in the
operational world so
you might be productionizing an asset
for low latency high velocity scoring as
part of a line of business application
or you might be
productionizing an asset for doing batch
kind of you know inference or data
engineering
but the key thing though is you want to
have a collaborative environment between
science and engineering so that they
work together using the pull request
mechanism to
in introduce software engineering rigor
into their code such that the data
scientist still understands
and is still signed onto the process
because then the data scientists can
still make meaningful changes and push
those things into production
and because the engineers have already
orchestrated all of this non-interactive
testing
then there's no reason in theory given
some stage gates that the data
scientists can't push things into
production but
your the second part of your question is
the data scientists should be able to
have freedom to explore
and there has to be limits to that in
the enterprise because
we have there are risk and governance
models and
you need to have data stewardship and
data governance you need to be very
careful about
what data that these folks can get
access to we already have
processes for example in most companies
around removing pii
information personally identifiable
information and having
buckets of enriched and conformed and
sanitized data that data scientists can
have access to so there needs to be some
process there
and they need to work in an isolated
environment in the cloud so that no data
is leaking
there's typically a scratch pad branch
like when you're doing
a pull request you can just clone out a
new branch and do a scratch pad there
the the trick if you want to do quick
experimentation and not
care about anything the trick is when
you're putting that back in
make sure it's good so like between the
start of the day and the middle of the
day do whatever you want just tidy it up
before you
turn off the lights for the night yeah
before sharing
sharing it out just make sure it's well
understandable and stuff like that yeah
i get that point yeah definitely
an amazing example that we get to see
here is where you have that sort of
philosophy of marrying
research practice into engineering
pipelines is a library called hugging
face
the folks at hugging face are constantly
pushing the boundary of nlp
by incorporating well-researched stuff
into their you know production pipelines
and stuff so i just wanted to
share that out here and we need to get
thomas wolfe on the podcast
yeah i i did have an interview so did
are you lucky
can you guys put a good word in for us
definitely why not amazing
on that note papers with code is doing
really good things in this space as well
not just benchmarking papers
independently but like
showing that there are research benefits
for writing good code
because those papers tend to get much
more views and therefore much more
citations
people can actively see if you want
state of the art
where that lives i think developments in
that direction are
probably the way to go in the near or
short to mid term
in the ideal world and i think this is a
feature that you just introduced in
driverless ai which
essentially allows you to create a
leaderboard you'd want to have that
leaderboard okay this model is
xyz percent performant and xyz percent
interpretable and now you have this nice
leaderboard of everything and anything
and you can
pick and choose what you like in the
ideal world we'd like to have
that leaderboard for almost all of the
problems how much do you how much do you
think the
this current divide that we've been
we've been talking about this divide for
a couple of minutes now
and i feel that we come from this world
of software engineering where you had
great works like the gang of four and
you had all these
patterns coming from java you had
patterns for this patterns for that
and it's not patterns aren't the best
way of doing something but it's like a
standardized way of doing something if
my java class is called blah blah blah
blah blah blah blah factory producer
consumer
i know what it's doing and bean in fact
recruiter consumer bean
and how much do you think
machine learning or data science still
has to go in that direction
where we'll have a common kind of common
patterns that are understood by the
whole community
and the second part is this even
possible
or are we trying to software engineer
our world of data science because
it's fundamentally different in software
engineering a customer comes
and you do requirements engineering and
after requirements engineering what has
to be done
what has to come out but in machine
learning
i remember the gang of four patterns and
this was back in the early days
of java for example i don't know if you
noticed this as well but when the latter
versions of
say c sharp came out the patterns were
built into the language
so because i remembered that reading
head first design patterns i used to
make
i used to run a software company i'd get
all of my employees to read that book
and in the latter years
it was just irrelevant because it was
built into the language
and now it's built into the framework
and also these patterns
that they're designed to modularize and
reduce the complexity of your code like
in python it's really puzzled and
transparent i don't think
we have a problem with that but the
problem is more
that we're doing this continuous kind of
transformations in vector spaces and we
and it's data driven i don't think we've
got a problem with people not
understanding the code do we
there are i think there are different
dimensions right first is obvious
can you put out clunky unclean code of
course not
would you want to test it to some extent
yes would you want to test every single
line
in production in uh development
who knows if you were having this
conversation in 2016 you'd say
oh image models take a lot of resources
you need to figure out how to deal with
those now that's transformers
nlp takes more resources somewhat
compared to images and again you can see
these are two different clubs
now if an industry is working in image
they would have different best practices
compared to someone who's putting a
model of
if someone is putting a transformer
model into production and
i think we need to figure it out can we
put out a universal practice
i i don't think so who knows if someone
puts a gun into production i'm sure
someone might have already what are the
best practices there can we
use the same bulletin notice and send it
over to someone who's working in a
different
industry i don't think so would
their startup agree with an enterprises
regulatory model
or the model that a highly regulated
industry is falling
again i don't think so apropos of
nothing have you guys seen
a hello world enterprise edition before
this is going to be good this is going
to be an alex special
right oh that is genius i i can't
remember
where i saw this but i think more
product managers need to take a look at
this
does it have proper dependency injection
though oh it does
you saw the interface if you i didn't go
into the the back end of it but there's
about like 20 or 30 folders of modules
that go into it
it's ridiculous nice in a more
abstract sense this idea of testability
and so on with machine learning we're
essentially trying to solve
problems that let's say we can't
code the solution for directly so we're
essentially trying to solve
problems that we don't exactly know how
to formulate the solution to
is there a limit to the testability of
these methods let's say when we build
something like a gpt3
or even beyond it becomes
impossible can it become impossible to
test because
ultimately it knows better than we do
what should
come out at the other end and some of it
some of that comes to the data right
how do we test that part how do we know
did the data scientists
transform the data into a certain format
before running a certain experiment how
do we get that version of the data set
do we need to version data sets do we
need to control them as well
and how do we pass that on along with
the pipeline along with
instructions of treating it interesting
i think
there are concentric circles the first
part
is do we understand what's happening in
this model
very quickly the answer becomes no and
then the next part is can we test
what's in this model and i think as well
very quickly the answer becomes no
all what are we testing for well we are
testing for
out of domain generalization and
adversarial robustness mostly in an
engineering context
and all we can do as an ml engineer is
guess about the domain in which we can
test for this local generalization
because we're in this high dimensional
space so if you were
testing a dog classifier you would
create semantically equivalent
adversarial examples you would
turn the dog upside down you would make
the dog brown you would
make the dog bigger and smaller you
would change the environment
you would do all sorts of things that
you think might come up in production
that was not seen during training
and there's a limit to what you can do
how the hell would you test a gpt-3
model
it just boggles the mind i know marco
rubio airtel came up with this
checklist tool and i want to make a
video on that connor shorten made a
video on it i think we should get
marco rubio on the show to talk about it
but he came up with quite a codified
mechanism
for building tests and creating a
dashboard of tests against nlp models
and creating distractors and changing uh
what followed by a noun to to where
followed by a noun or
where you see question marks make it two
question marks and see if you can
oh that particular mutation might flip
two percent of the
the examples in the test set but
basically we're scratching around we
we have no idea how to do this in the
world of dog classifiers
top classes on self driving for the
adversarial attacks the adversarial
pixel attacks as well is there a way to
test them or is there an efficient way
that wouldn't allow the attackers to let
the car crash into the docks
done some research on this so i'll defer
to yannick
it's hopeless i thought so
yeah the thing is as well it's a little
bit like
every time you train a deep learning
model depending on your initialization
of the weights it goes into a different
basin of attraction
but the basin of attraction still gives
you roughly semantically equivalent
performance that's what i do i watch the
annex video so i'm just parroting what
yannick said that's the reason why
ensemble methods work so well but it's a
similar thing with adversarial examples
there are an infinite number of ways to
push
classifier off the decision boundary
which kind of seems to imply there are
uncountably many
adversarial examples
so it's completely hopeless okay so
there is a notion of
if one i don't know how much time we
have and this is a tangent but there is
a notion of
adversarial examples which i am a
believer in let's say because all this
space is like a religious space
where and i'm a follower of the cult of
madrid
and alexander madhuri has this
conception of adversarial examples
where there is a series of paper that
shows and the big one is called
adversarial examples
are features not bugs and
basically showing that there are
features
in the data that are useful for
learning the correct classes but which
are of such
small scale that those are basically
what make the adversarial examples
adversarial so what you're doing
essentially is you're going
and you're just changing that one
feature that is so small
but it is a useful feature and and that
means
necessarily there might not be
uncountably many adversarial examples
because there aren't uncountably
many features but
what you're basically doing is you're
raising this one feature and usually
that's correlated with all the other
features of bigger magnitude but now
it's not so
maybe there is a hope but what you have
to do
since this is a useful feature what you
have to do is basically stifle the
performance of your classifier
making it ignore all of those features
that are these small features and
then you'll get a weaker class but if
you could do that
if you could exclude all these features
that's the same
difficulty as uh solving the adversarial
problem itself
so so it that's why i'm saying it's
hopeless is that the network
ultimately doesn't care how big like i'm
talking about feature magnitudes
so a classifier can classify a dog by
the fact that it has a snout
and a tail and four legs and so on but a
classifier can also classify a dog
by the fine structure of its fur that is
only particular to that kind of of dog
so i'm talking about these magnitudes
and it
these small magnitude features they can
be very predictive
there's also there's this also notion of
shape versus textures
because we as humans are more accustomed
to shapes for recognizing images and
stuff like that but
we have evidences that show that the
state-of-the-art deep learning models
are probably not they're more inclined
toward
the textures of images in order to
classify them and there's this iclear
2019 paper
that demonstrates this and they suggest
stylization
as an alternative to cater to this but
later
that year dan hendricks at all proposed
that natural adversarial examples do not
follow any of that right
because of the inherent properties of
these examples and stuff like
associating a particular image with many
objects to only one
this all of these problems contribute to
the prob
the broader problem of associating
models toward
textures instead of shapes and stuff
like that so
yeah the hopeless nature is i can i
agree
with you so it's very vague at this
point in time
amazing sonia if you could go back in
time and give your younger self some
advice
what would it be i'm still not wise
enough to
give some pieces of advice to myself
even my younger self
yeah my journey has been driven by
interest and curiosity a lot of the
things i've done
are stupid from any standpoint i would
still do them i wouldn't change that
i terminated all of my contracts which
were pretty good at that time
all of my bay areas income to start a
podcast with no plans about it
just because i enjoy it so well
it's all about exploration isn't it you
don't know where it might lead and as
you said as well we all make stupid
mistakes in our lives but
you can't shortcut you need to make
those stupid mistakes don't you
i enjoy what i do and i have been for
for a long time so i
i think i'll just continue that i
wouldn't change anything
even it's cannot take shortcuts
[Laughter]
amazing folks thank you so much i i
invite everyone to go and subscribe to
uh samyam's
podcast and youtube channel he's got
some amazing guests on there it's a
great inspiration to have him on the
show
and i've really enjoyed having this
conversation with you folks today so
thank you so much
thank you thanks for the opportunity and
i i hope i didn't lose mlst any
subscribers if you watch this episode
you wouldn't you wouldn't want to switch
over to ctds uh continue watching the
show it's much more of a depth i i would
also suggest that you check out
psyx blog post i really enjoyed that
janik's channel i love it
audio podcast as well uh so thanks for
the opportunity uh
and i really enjoyed this thank you oh
it's an absolute pleasure thank you so
much
thank you ready folks bye